بالتزامن مع زياده اعداد المعتمرين مقارنه
بما كانت عليه قبل جائحه كورونا كشفت
مصادر للعربيه ان السعوديه استقبلت منذ
بدء موسم العمره الجاري الذي انطلق في
محرم الماضي نحو ثمانيه ملايين معتمر
بمختلف انواع التاشيرات حول الاستعدادات
لموسم العمره في شهر رمضان اعلنت رئاسه
شؤون الحرمين عن قطتها التي تضمنت توفير
اكثر من عشرين الف من الكوادر البشريه
استعدادا لاستقبال وخدمه ضيوف الرحمن
ينضم الينا من جده الدكتور عمرو المداح
وكيل وزاره الحج والعمره لخدمات الحجاج
والمعتمرين دكتور عمرو مرحبا بك هل
الاستعدادات تختلف في موسم العمره هذا
العام عن الموسم
اولا بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم طبعا موسم
العمره هذا السنه احنا نتحدث عن اعداد
يعني الاعلى على مر السنوات الماضيه
والموسم هذا يختلف عن الاعوام السابقه نحن
نعود بعد الجائحه باعداد كبيره الان يعني
اذا شاهدنا القنوات والبث المباشر
للمسجد الحرام سنجد ان اعداد المعتمرين
المتواجدين في الحرم بشكل كبير على طوال
اليوم فاحنا الاستعدادات يجب ان تكون على
اجمل وجه خاصه انه ما زلنا لم ندخل في شهر
رمضان ونرى الاعداد الكبيره المتواجده
حاليا في المملكه وبالتالي يجب ان تعتمد
على ماذا هذه الاستعدادات الان
طبعا الاستعدادات على شقين الشق الاول
والتكامل والجاهزيه لمقدمي الخدمات من
شركات وقطاع خاص من العاملين في الاستقبال
على المباشره والخدمات
الارضيه المعتمرين وكذلك على عمليه
التنظيم في التنقلات بالحافلات وخلاف
والاستقبال في المطارات الجزء الثاني
والاهم هو عمليه التنسيق والتكامل في
القطط التشغيليه بين الجهات المختلفه سواء
حكوميه او قطاع خاص لانه رحله اداء العمره
والرحله زياره المسجد الحرام تتكون من
مجموعه من العمليات المترابطه والمتشعب
فبالتالي التنسيق والموامه على خاصه مع
تواجد اعداد كبيره بهذا الشكل في غايه
انتم حاطين رقم معين مستهدف او متوقع في
موسم العمره هذا العام
خصوصا مع التمرين الخارج
نحن نتحدث الان عن وصولنا الى ما يقارب
ثمانيه مليون معتمد بمختلف انواع
التاشيرات ادو العمره نتوقع مع نهايه شهر
رمضان هذا العام باذن الله ان نقارب 9
مليون معتمد باذن الله الزياده يعني بمعدل
مليونين تقريبا او اقل من ذلك
اشهر التي يقدم فيها المعتمرين من الخارج
مع متغير رئيسي هذه السنه هو وجود تاشيره
السياحه كذلك والتسهيلات التي حصلت في
مختلف انواع التاش
يرات على التاشيره
بغايه السهوله مما يساعد في قدوم اعداد
كثيره كذلك
بالتجهيزات المعدل الانستقبال هذا العدد
خاصه في شهر رمضان الى اي مدى ايضا تختلف
دكتور عامر
التجهيزات الان يعني مختلف الجهات
الحكوميه تبحث عن اتاحه الفرصه
المناسبه للمعتمرين القادمين خارج لزياره
المناسك واداء العمره
وزياره المسجد النبوي الشريف فهذا يتطلب
عمليات تنظيميه من الدخول الى المسجد
الحرام والمواعيد المتاحه لذلك دائما تلح
الاول الاولويه للقادمين من الخارج من
المعتمرين والزائرين للوصول لاداء العمره
وكذلك يتم ترتيب التنقلات بالحافلات
والحركه داخل المنطقه المركزيه بما يتيح
الوصول باذن الله بكل يسر وثلاثه العمليات
التنظيميه تختلف باختلاف الموسم وخاصه مع
قرب شهر رمضان والكثافه العدديه الكبيره
المتوقعه كذلك من داخل المملكه لكن نحرص
باذن الله على ان تكون كافه الخدمات
والاستعدادات
على اكمل وجبه ما يمثل الصوره التي نسعى
لها في خدمه المملكه
الدكتور تجديد والتطوير يمكن من اهم
الامور اللي ساهمت في انجاح يعني رحله
الحاج وكذلك المؤتمر هي المساله التقنيه
والتكنولوجيه بالتالي الى اي مدى تخدمكم
وهل نتوقع ايضا تطوير في في تقديم هذه
الخدمه للمعتمر خلال فتره القادمه
بكل داخل المملكه وخارجها لعمليه تطوير
الخدمه تطوير الخدمات المقدمه لضيوف
يعتمد بشكل كبير على التحول الرقمي الذي
تشهده المملكه وتشهده منظومه قمه ضيوف
الرحمن بشكل خاص لذلك اطلقت الوزاره وزاره
الحج والعمره بالشراكه مع وزاره السياحه
وتحت مظله برنامج خدمه ضيوف الرحمن
النشط ونسكي لهويه التسويقيه الان التي
نسعى من خلالها لتسهيل وتقديم كافه
الخدمات التي يرغب بها ضيف الرحمن ومنها
اطلاق المنصه والبوابه الالكترونيه نسق
وتم اطلاق التطبيق الالكتروني كذلك هذا
التطبيق سيشهد في المرحله القادمه باذن
الله زياده خدمات المتاحه بما يسهل على
الضيف الرحمن كامل مراحل
الاسعار دكتور تعرف انه بعض المعتمرين من
خارج المملكه يعانون مساله ارتفاع الاسعار
تعاملهم مع بعض الشركات ربما في بلادهم
هنا هنا
هل هناك اي دور لوزاره الحج والعمره في
معالجه هذه المشكله
[موسيقى]
فان الاسعار يتم عرضها بشفافيه واضحه
وكذلك يتم متابعتها ومراقبتها لضمان تقديم
الخدمه بشكل صحيح وفي حال وجود اي مخالفه
تقصير الوزاره تضمن الخدمه المقدمه شكرا
لك دكتور عمرو المداح وكيل وزاره الحج
والعمره لخدمات الحجاج والمعتمرين من